c'est vrai que ramzi puis il a une
personne voilà c'est son coup de coeur
on l'a dit à l'heure et michael c tous
les copains de ghazi le savent
sa femme le sait si je te le dis c'est
qu'il est fou amoureux
[Applaudissements]
ça me semblerait tout à fait normal en
réalité c'est un leurre c'est à dire
c'est d'ailleurs on vous a dit ça tout à
l'heure oui c'est un leurre avant c'est
à dire c'est une autre personne qu'il
kiffe
ah bon qui fait une autre personne oui
ramzy oui ici oui on a laissé passer une
partie des établissements
oui séraline au sein du groupe au sein
du groupe
là dans l'émission dans les messieurs
depuis de longues années
y at il eu quelqu'un pardon ici m
[Rires]
ramzy ne ment pas on sait tous que c'est
kelly mais tu es meilleur côté serge et
nancy n'ont 0 c'est pas moi c'est
michael mais pourquoi c'est si je ne
voulais pas le dire je produis le
franchement aussi gilles carrez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce sentiment ne se contrôle pas du
neveu s'est passé la même chose pour lui
et zemmour bon il est temps qu'ils
[Rires]
savent pas qui c'est et mauricie j'ai vu
j'applaudis moussa appelant à toujours
moins essayer de sauver le coup là mais
c'est vrai que je veux dire qu'il est
apprécié beaucoup aussi un récit du seul
coup c'est pas possible c'est marqué il
entend donner aux jeunes alors je te
tiens je te connais bien c'est un ami je
ne les fais tu t'appelles martin il
fallait que tu deviennes une possibilité
at il dit il est 12h15 gmt doit pas
parler d'autre chose
c'est ce qu'on va retenir son nom peut
avoir un coup de grâce est un truc qui
restent secrètes où l'agent quand même
est-ce que tu peux te retourne toi et tu
vas parler son convoi ton visage nous
est peut-être tombé raide que tu vas
être deux allez savoir mais non mais
j'aime mais enfin ça prend des
proportions non mais ce que fait gaffe
c'est un gars sensible très sensible
j'ai eu dans les bras train de pleurer
un brin l'amci est ce que oui ou non je
te tape sur l'épaule si tu réponds si tu
devais si tu devais faire ce mois là
j'ai pas compris et orlando n'a tiqué
elle te dis voilà tu peux partir avec
qui tu veux pendant et non et non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment des questions dans
l'école arle à toi ton perrine énorme
voiture ils te donnent à toi tu as deux
ans non non c'est pas du tout ça va être
une semaine
ah oui tu veux te retourner complètement
oui voici une semaine avec une personne
est-ce que c'est kelly et commencé avec
une personne qui fait il choisit une
personne dans le monde pour passer une
semaine en amoureux mais sa femme lui
donne le ticket est ce que ce serait
kenya ou pas et ne ment pas mais si sa
faim mais donne politique email
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
retournez dans mais qu'est ce que tu dis
que je suis un mais deux c'est déjà géré
ses risques chez qui le serbe anna g j
est ce que oui ou non c'est kelly est ce
que c'est qu'il dit oui c'est qu'elle
est
[Applaudissements]
je fais du bien et les cherry avait rien
sur le coeur à soulager qui tu m'as n'a
pas long un dîner entier qu'elle est il
a bu je sais pas ce soir là mais alors
qui a dit martin ça c'est kelly alors
kelly martin qui est notre question est
ce que tu peux t'occuper de télé ce que
tu peux l'interroger c'est top mais n'a
dérogé sur quoi le fameux ticket au oui
il me suit de très gênant n'aura donc
qu'elle y voilà est-ce que du frais la
bêtise
évidemment non non mais moi ça non mais
non mais je ne veux même pas tu as rêvé
rêvé asthme quoi il peut rêver
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais ne répond pas
si on veut la réponse mais nous y sommes
pourquoi vous aviez musique d'ascenseur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette musique d'ascenseur
oui j'aime réponses possibles et micha
même sens en haïti alors elle a une
réponse positive mais parce que ça vous
intéresse
nomi je suis malgré tout va bien alors
en défense visite secrète avec sa red
[Applaudissements]
bull semblent assez fort la femme et ta
femme c'est ta femme est même qui nous a
dit qu'elle était d'accord d'un ticket
pas tant parce que en fait dans une
fiction aux nombres hui doré dans la
fiction un fantasme comme cette fiction
je sais pas écrire maintenant message ou
content que si ces noms mal m'a appelé
avant les tactiques et sur toi c'est la
troupe où les partis c'est le dit oui ou
par témoin prend tout de suite une
semaine la tactique et sur toile ah
ouais bon bah merci s'il vous plaît mais
pourquoi cette intervention juste g dit
allez viens on rame ci est ce que c'est
vrai qu'on a par là ta femme ou pas dit
la vérité je n'ai parlé with me donner
devant notre télé oui les codes
il a beaucoup tourné il est fatigué on
dit n'importe quoi à la télé ne disait
pas la barre noble ce que tu nous a dit
que c'était vrai oui mais bon
alors est ce que tu veux la réponse est
ce que tu veux la réponse positive de
cali oui c'est effectivement une réponse
positive c'est qu'en fait tu ne sais pas
et l'autre personne ne le sait pas mais
j'ai dans le milieu et ça vient que de
moi c'est pas réciproque pas encore du
moins
mais j'ai vu ce qui va deux grands
frères être spirituel et tu en fais
partie ah merde ses passions ses moyens
faire ce rituel les à ses moyens et de
ses toits et kery james
voilà c'est génial vous êtes dans mon
coeur depuis des années des années des
années et je pense à toi c'est bon en
plus que c'était vraiment mon grand
frère spire tube spirituel lui qui est
beaucoup plus jeune qu à l'époque et
mobilité oui l'homme et ça me touche et
non mais vraiment en plus au stif
beaucoup battu voix christian [ __ ]
d'idée derrière sa baisse beaucoup de
repas est inquiète pas là on s'est dit
les choses ma main volontaire alors
voilà ben c'est bien là
[Applaudissements]
le message est clair et de voilà c'est
bien